son montréal lancent un cri d eau de cri
du coeur et cri d'alarmé afin de
recueillir un maximum de denrées et de
dons pour les tout petits les enfants
âgés de 0 à 5 ans et mathieu didion
c'est la troisième campagne du genre
mené on parle surtout de ses campagnes
générales dans le temps des fêtes
et c'est quand même la troisième
campagne du genre menée par moisson
montréal jusqu'ici et l'organisme n'a
pas encore atteint ses objectifs
ils ont besoin de dons en argent des
denrées des produits pour les bébés des
couches de la nourriture
et si ils entreposent sur les tablettes
les produits pour les enfants les
produits pour les bébés
et vous allez le voir c'est loin d'être
remplis alors on est loin de l'objectif
surtout que pendant cette campagne d'un
mois on espérait recueillir jusqu'à 200
mille dollars
mais à une semaine de la fin de cette
campagne on a requis qu'entre 20 et 30
mille dollars
donc oui on est loin de l'objectif c'est
le cas de le dire
et c'est donc ces denrées sont destinés
à 20 les tout petits de 0 à 5 ans dans
la grande région de montréal qui
souffrent de faim vingt mille c'est près
de l'équivalent de la capacité du centre
bell alors ça vous donne une idée
et même si l'entrepôt ici les vastes ce
sont moins de 1% des produits qui sont
destinés aux bébés
alors vous le disiez noël c'est souvent
la période où on donne beaucoup et là
c'est la période creuse alors moisson
montréal cette banque alimentaire soit
de faire de la période de pâques une
nouvelle période où on donne on lance un
site du coeur aux gens on s'approche de
la date limite c'est très important que
les attend à battre cette campagne on
n'en parle pas beaucoup
on a 200 blessés pas excessif avons
demandé aux gens de donner un coup de
main il reste à peine cette pluie de
dijon au parc sans avis on va dans
l'abondance et les gens vont penser aux
enfants pour le championnat mais pas
dans ça l'est vraiment des jeunes bébés
qui ont besoin d'être largement nos gens
travaillent
un coup de main bon mathieu concrètement
les gens qui veulent aider qui veulent
soutenir cette campagne qu'est ce qu'il
peut
qu'est ce qu'ils peuvent faire ils
peuvent donner de la nourriture des
petits pots pour bébé ou encore à des
couches absolument nécessaire pour ces
tout petits de 0 à 5 ans on donne on ne
demande pas ici nécessairement des
vêtements ou des jouets on entre
vraiment de la nourriture de l'argent et
vous pouvez aussi donner dans les
combats de toutes les pharmacies uniprix
du québec et des contenants pour
recueillir les dons en argent et les
denrées pour ces tout petits en détresse
merci beaucoup monsieur merci au revoir
au revoir